hello and welcome to this video playing
drama da from Sweden Jesper hall let's
see what jasper is doing here against by
g6 we okay yeah this is basically virgin
territory for me I have haven't even
looked at this line in some in some
detail I just figured that way tonight
takes is 69 takes yeah it's okay it's
okay knight c6 pawn takes Queen da
drooped yet but should be seven but
doesn't really doesn't really hurt me so
this one could be could be quite
weakening yeah probably still it's funny
still as knight c6 tactically
when i get i get i get i get this i get
this pawn back 96b takes Queen dat Queen
the group the eighth Bishop e7 rook e8
Bishop c5 i will get this e4 pawn back
somehow even with bishop xiii maybe but
this is not a dream move yeah I think I
was more concerned about this oh yeah 96
I can take and I can take no I have g 5
i'm sorry okay so let's see 5f g5 very
important he might have night a five
though I thought we should be seven yeah
yeah I have to go g5 I think no
alternative but isn't that ok it should
be ok mm-hmm
yeah I think probably just bishop chair
5 therefore I thought is a strategic
mistake to be honest that makes its own
bishop even worse but we'll see will
seem 95 c 6 is interesting if this is a
good spot for the night or not I don't
think so but maybe it is Oh interesting
we should to see three SS idn and I
think so how to do this book III a queen
to have sex
look you for is also interesting try to
double I'm not not totally sure but
let's let's start with this yeah looks
normal but maybe if we just trade stuff
and it doesn't lead to much will seem
okay what is this night doing them
I'm when they're just killing him there
on the second rank it's kind of strange
Queen d1 Bishop c2 yeah that was just a
slip here ok so 2500 yes always funny to
get to that get to that school yeah it
was an interesting game this g six lines
are interesting to get ya unexplored
positions so here we ate yeah i just
want to show one of those tactics yeah
it's funny yet it cannot take with the
night have to take with this and at the
end we have this this situation ruki
eight and i'm fine now because this is
hanging i also have this and take on the
voids it's probably equal ish so c5
again this was a possibility but
ultimately not leading to much probably
it's better for blankets better for
Blackmon so we went back and played e6
again now night c5 didn't work due to g5
so 95 and now I think this is fine Queen
takes bishop e6 looks good and this is
also looking good yeah for I was
surprised okay the computer wants to
play Queen to f6 Wow ok I understand
that the technical point he wants to
play this this is covered and then you
maybe get be too it's just that this
looks strange but ok the bishop will
have a very strong square on your form
ok i just played a strategically normal
move let's say and this is nice it's got
many weaknesses
and yes I think just rookie one try to
trade stuff maybe this is this is
looking looking very strange now after
this it's basically over quindi one
Bishop see tool or quincy one looks it
too and the next look is coming it's so
yeah that's disastrous for white some it
was a well deserved them well justified
resignation ok guys thanks for watching